Donald Trump is now visibly panicking
about not only the existing arrest that
already took place but about possible
forthcoming arrests and he has declared
that Joe Biden is guilty in another one
of these sick orange swollen videos with
the bizarre Lighting in this clip Donald
Trump attacks the special prosecutor
Jack Smith as a lunatic and says that
Biden is guilty not exactly Law and
Order is it to say someone who hasn't
even been uh in charged or there's no
evidence that Biden's guilty of anything
he said no he he's guilty Trump hating
prosecutor Jack Smith a lunatic
should go get Biden for what he did he's
very guilty very
Biden is not just guilty he's very very
guilty and this is of course another
example of what I spoke to you about on
geez was it Tuesday or Wednesday the
abandonment of their own stated
principles by Republicans were about Law
and Order and due process
are you though because you want the
January 6 rioters to get special
treatment you want Hillary and you want
Biden and you want Obama
locked up even though they haven't even
been charged with any crimes and you're
now declaring people guilty of course
without ever explaining what crimes you
even think they committed when people
ask Trump what what is Obama gate anyway
he says you know what it is it's the
biggest political crime of the century
oh yeah but like what laws were violated
no that's that's fake news that question
is fake news this entire thing
continuing
with Donald Trump uh going through his
typical grievances including that every
investigation of him is a scam eighty
percent of the public think that
your former president Donald J Trump me
is being treated very unfairly for
political reasons and due to the fact
that he is leading in all of the polls I
love this third person stuff
he Trump is leading
eighty percent of the people agree with
that
I say these prosecutorial scams and
hoaxes are all about election
interference and Republican leadership
must get tough and must be smart but
we're not going to have a country left
yep there will be no country left if
Trump is held accountable for the things
he allegedly did Trump then uh Trump
Furious I guess now with Republicans who
don't like him who are continuing to be
furious he actually tells people if you
turn on the TV even if you're watching
Fox News if you see Karl Rove there or
Bill Barr or Paul Ryan you got to turn
that TV off
bar or Paul Ryan on your television
screen just turn to a different station
or turn it off turn off that set as fast
as you can you're frankly better off
watching Democrats they are the worst
yep so this is basically I don't want
you to hear any of the things that some
Republicans are saying about me because
not every Republican likes me so just
turn the TV off kind of treating his
followers like little children just
don't even let them watch it don't let
them think for themselves Trump then
going back to his obsession about
Chinese restaurants and Chinatown when
it comes to documents when will they be
looking at the Biden documents many of
which were brought in from Chinatown
and then sent to Boston
is this why China paid him and Hunter
millions and millions of dollars now
many of you are wondering what the hell
is Trump talking about Chinatown
Trump seized on some story whose details
I previously researched and sort of
escaped me now where there was a period
during which the during which Nara the
National Archives
was temporarily storing some documents I
believe for a Presidential Library
in a building that previously housed a
laundry and also a Chinese restaurant if
I recall correctly and now it's about
China Town and it's it's it's just
Insanity that this is still something
Trump is focusing on and then of course
lastly this is a common way that Trump
wraps speeches declaring himself the
most honest person ever anywhere not
just among American Presidents but just
anywhere after eight years of various
politically motivated investigations
hoaxes scams and witch hunts this must
make me the most honest and honorable
man anywhere in the world must nobody in
history has ever been through the
scrutiny that I have
we're going to make America great again
we are going to get rid of these
lunatics there you go well we I am all
for getting rid of lunatics that is
absolutely the case so what is causing
Trump to be triggered in this way it's
actually not completely clear so let's
go through it if you look at polling the
polling is like not great for Trump in
the general but it's very good in the
primary we look at recent general
election polls we've got a yougov
economist poll a b-plus rated poll which
was released two days ago Biden versus
Trump this one has Trump up one among
registered voters and it has uh Trump up
four among uh what is the I actually
don't remember what the a stands for is
this all voters will registered I'm not
sure what that is a okay uh there is an
earlier yougov poll sponsored by Yahoo
news which has Trump up to over Joe
Biden but with only something like uh 70
of respondents choosing one or the other
um Biden versus Trump in a morning
consult poll it's Biden plus three okay
so like it's roughly even with Biden you
could say if you then look at Republican
primary polls Trump is just crushing I
mean again as I said before unless
something really changes unless DeSantis
enters this race
with some kind of Blockbuster and
something terrible happens to Donald
Trump I don't see how DeSantis is going
to be the guy to beat him in a new
yougov poll Trump is ahead of DeSantis
by 22.
um in a Yahoo news you gov poll Trump is
ahead of DeSantis by 24. University of
New Hampshire Poll for the New Hampshire
primary Trump leads by 20.
um it it's really very strong for Donald
Trump so is the polling the reason that
Trump is flipping out
doesn't seem to be is it that Donald
Trump is catching wind that actually
being under indictment in New York
already and potentially more forthcoming
indictments are really going to get in
the way of him being able to run the
campaign he wants to run it when he
wants to do more rallies in the entire
thing that could be and in fact there
have been rumors that by the end of this
month April although at this point it
doesn't it's not clear it's going to
happen there were rumors that Trump's
second arrest was going to take place uh
in the last week of April maybe Trump
has caught wind of that it's not really
clear and then thirdly is there
something going on in terms of
fundraising and big donors where Trump
is quietly hearing that there are big
donors he would like to have in his
Corner who are going to either wait or
go to SanDisk or someone else it's a
total hypothetical and again we are not
seeing evidence of that in fact at the
top of the show today I told you about
the reality that many DeSantis would-be
Mega donors are furious with them and
saying what the hell is he doing leaving
Florida when there's flooding in gas
lines uh I'm not going to donate to
DeSantis so that also doesn't seem to be
the reason that Trump would be so
triggered we don't actually know the
answer and I think one of the things we
have to come to terms with is that with
Donald Trump there is often no obvious
explanation for his erratic Behavior
after the break I am briefly going to
talk to you about a more specific sort
of kerfuffle that came out of this uh
video which is Trump's much more direct
focus on Ron DeSantis which has a lot of
interesting things underlying it we'll
get to that after the break if you or
one of your parents is starting to lose
your hearing you're not alone about 48
million Americans have hearing loss and
only one in five people who would
benefit from using a hearing aid are
actually using one our sponsors MD
hearing create FDA registered
rechargeable hearing aids that cost a
fraction of what you typically pay for
example MD hearing's new Neo model costs
less than 10 percent of what those
marked up hearing aids are being sold
for at most hearing clinics and the Neo
is MD hearings smallest hearing aid ever
no one will even know that it's there I
have a close family friend who uses MD
hearing and loves it she said it
performs better than any hearing aid
that she's used and it's far less
noticeable MD hearing even offers a
45-day risk-free trial with a 100
percent money back guarantee so you can
buy with confidence and they have a
special deal for my audience when you
buy a pair of hearing aids you'll get
them for just 149.99 each plus they'll
include a free extra charging case go to
mdhearing.com and use the code Pacman
the link is down below